good design simply give happiness to
people
my name is Anton Shira I'm the principal
and founder of shura Studio I'm the lead
designer for Turbo Eco Park
[Music]
tabernico Park is a 7.3 hectare public
park located in Jakarta
there was three challenge when we
encountered turbo Eco Park for the first
time first the park was operated by the
main road in Canal this creates a
disconnect
second the existing figuration has been
degraded because of the frequent
flooding
and the third it was a garbage dumping
site
to take out the Echo Park challenge we
have to repair the site ecologists
means we have to walk sensitively with
the existing major trees second we have
to repair the environment by
naturalizing the kennel because the
canal has an insufficient capacity
and the third one is to create a
multiple recreational community space to
accommodate different backgrounds and
users
we create a bridge that is Meandering
through the toolbox
the bridge is not just functioning to
connect the parks but create a memorable
experience when people walking through
this park
when the park was opened in April 2022
we received an overwhelming positive
response from many communities
it opened the government eye that public
is demanding good public parks in
Jakarta
a year after completion we visited the
park again and we have seen this
increment of wildlife coming back to the
park it shows a good sign that with a
right approach we can create a part in
high density area to bring back what has
been lost
Singapore public parks project has been
a role model for many Southeast Asian
countries due to the similar climates
and conditions
coming from the singapore-based practice
it really helps to convince all the
consultants and the stakeholders on what
we want to do because we have done it
and proof it in Singapore
winning this award it boosts our
confidence that what we are doing is on
the right track
I have to keep the Fate in the design
process Trust on what we are doing keep
innovating and never stop learning
foreign